I meet Paula Abdul I'm looking for a yes
are you guys ready for this song we are
switching it up this time it's gonna be
out and out energy it sort of felt like
you guys went a little more trying to be
like a little more groovy hip hop being
from Levi that's your uniqueness don't
break that traditional aspect of what
you're bringing that's different from
everybody
there's one area when you guys are in
the line can you guys get an affirmation
with this position you in a straddle
position but I kept using these terms
like strategy talking about this one
you're in a straddle your legs are
straddled
trying to flip it back to this way we
were trying to understand what she wants
us to do so we could India and we
couldn't see you guys are very raw like
you said straddling really everyone has
to hit the same bent meet how if you're
taller you need to drop down a little
lower and so that you're all reading is
one because it's beautiful there are a
lot of hip hop action have division but
nobody that's what we do the only rest
once the whole competition is over and
it goes in our favor
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]